a former worker for an immigrant shelter
in Arizona is charged with eleven sex
offenses after he was accused of
molesting eight unaccompanied boys in
his care a new report by Pro Publica
highlights the allegations against
Lavigne Pacheco the alleged abuse took
place over about a year and a shelter
run by Southwest kee near Phoenix Don
Dahler shows us how that organization
has faced other incidents of alleged
abuse Don good morning good morning
southwest key is the largest
organization the US government contracts
to house immigrant children and has
eight shelters in Arizona alone it's now
coming under intense scrutiny for
repeated incidents of sexual abuse
happening to young immigrant children in
their care at several shell toes one of
the boys decided to speak up about what
had happened to him and then it was kind
of a snowfall where another boy the
roommate spoke up and it also happened
to him
Michael Gray Bell is one of the
ProPublica reporters who uncovered the
details of abuse at the southwest key
shelter Le'Veon Pacheco who is
hiv-positive
was indicted for engaging in sexual acts
with at least eight boys between August
2016 and July 2017 at Casa Kokopelli in
Mesa Arizona all the children were
between 15 and 17 years old it's very
common for victims of abuse to not come
forward to be afraid to come forward and
especially in this population there is
this fear that if you come forward and
report abuse it might affect her
immigration case on Tuesday another
Southwest key worker Fernando Negrete
was arrested and later fired after
allegedly molesting a 14 year old
immigrant girl at a facility in Phoenix
in a statement southwest Key said we
educate every miner in our care of their
right to be free from abuse any employee
accused of abuse is immediately
suspended and law enforcement called I
think the best way to describe them is
to be more like a summer camp following
backlash over the Trump administration's
child separation policy officials
defended the use of the detention
facilities as safe spaces these shelters
were never intended to
long term group homes and we've heard
from various officials various
psychologists that the longer the kids
are in the shelter the more time there
is for inappropriate relationships
develop the Department of Health and
Human Services told us they have removed
all kids from the casa co capella
shelter and that any allegation of abuse
or neglect is taken seriously and
appropriate action is taken Pacheco's
attorney did not respond to our request
for comment but in an email to the
Associated Press said we are looking
forward to defending mr. Pacheco in
court he has pleaded not guilty and will
be in court later this month
very disturbing deeply deeply disturbing
story about a deeply disturbing issue
Thank You Don